[Applaudissements]
une victoire convaincante et un succès
historique
de quoi motiver encore plus les 350
mille jeunes joueurs de basketball
organisée du pays
à droite du côté des visiteurs va 13 ans
un regard intense et des ambitions
gigantesques ils rêvent d'atteindre la
nba pour inspirer à son tour des
milliers de jeunes
celui qui a fait connaître le basketball
dans notre pays amoureux
ok c'est lui 24 premières supervedette
developpers champion des concours
d'habiletés à 31 ans tharonne grand bol
fait partie de la génération raptors qui
a succombé à l'effet carter il est allé
jouer au basketball aux états unis à une
époque où peu de canadiens se
passionnait pour ce sport n'était pas
pratique et sérieusement ici dit il
c'est jour et la nuit avec aujourd'hui
tyrone grand bol a fondé toronto city
élite il y a quatre ans l'une des
nombreuses académies de basket ball qui
ont récemment vu le jour au pays zain
mahmoud est un géant de 13 ans inspirées
par les raptors séduit par le basketball
ciné-débat bordry est emballé par les
portes qui s'ouvrent aux joueurs d'ici
onze joueurs canadiens dont le torontois
andrew higgins évolué dans la nba et 24
ont participé au tournoi universitaire
américain en mars
hadzibegic fait partie de ces vedettes
montantes qui se retrouveront bientôt
chez les professionnels le montréalais
kris boucher a complété ses études en
oregon et il réalise son rêve avec les
acteurs pour moi c'est ça que je voulais
avoir je voulais voir des gens qui
quittent le pays
puis qu'ils vont faire de leur propre
appui qui reviennent et qui montre
l'exemple alors si je sais pas si ça
sera toujours notre mère à voir tous ces
jeunes se passionnait pour les oies
rieuses
une chose est sûre le basket ball n'a
pas fini de gagner en popularité ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto